Buenas tardes es un día de Caos Porque
además de los profesores de colegios de
universidades los consultores de los
trenes de los buses funcionarios del
Estado también se han sumado a esta
movilización que como lo mencionabas es
considerada la más grande de la última
década en el caso de los profesores de
colegios de Inglaterra y gales el 85% de
estos se ha sumado al cese de
actividades creando caos para millones
de niños en el caso del transporte
público en los trenes aquí en el sur de
Londres he podido ir algunas estaciones
de tren están completamente cerradas por
supuesto pero los trabajadores están en
las afueras conparcatas tratando de
explicarles a la población Por qué están
en huelga y dicen que lo único que piden
es que se mejoren sus condiciones
laborales Lo cierto es que es una
situación bien compleja y que sigue
complicándose todos los días porque la
próxima semana Hay nuevas jornadas de
huelgas enfermeras y de otros sectores
poniendo muchísima más presión al
gobierno Luisa que dice el gobierno
frente a las peticiones de los
manifestantes Y qué efecto podrían tener
estas movilizaciones sociales en el
gobierno de Richi sonak
el gobierno les ha pedido a los
diferentes sindicatos de los diferentes
sectores que están marchando desde el
dos que hagan propuestas realistas que
estén acordes con la inflación con la
crisis que vive el país pero lo cierto
Es que esas expectativas esas propuestas
que ha hecho el gobierno están muy por
debajo de los deseos de los
requerimientos que hacen los diferentes
sindicatos y por ello no ha habido luz
verde y los diferentes sectores del país
están pidiéndoles a las partes que se
sienten a negociar una vez más por el
futuro del país pero como bien lo
mencionas Esta es movilización Es que
dan la sensación de una huelga general
ponen contra las cuerdas a Richie sunak
su gobierno que se revela muy débil
políticamente y que tendrá un efecto por
supuesto en su gobierno pero también en
el futuro del partido conservador porque
pareciera que el gobierno de Richie es
una no tiene control del país y esto
puede ser muy y peligroso de Cara a las
elecciones generales de 2024 en la que
cada vez más los laboristas el partido
en oposición le está pisando los talones
a los turis